what's up everybody
a lot of buzz going around right now we
are all wondering if Korg is going to be
in Avengers four hey Daisy
allow me to introduce myself my name is
cork I'm kind of like the leader in here
there's a photo that came out that could
possibly reveal some information we'll
talk about what this means I'm still
doing my giveaway so if you'd like to
enter for your chance to win a copy of
Avengers infinity war on blu-ray
a special edition poster and some
special memorabilia all you have to do
to enter is subscribe to my channel like
this video and comment below with your
thoughts and your favorite superhero so
here's the picture that was recently
released as you can see many of the
Marvel family members are here we can
see Marvel Studios President Kevin Feige
is there with Chris Evans Scarlett
Johansson Maria Tomei and many others
but as you can also see Tycho OTT is
there so everyone sort of freaking out
about this photo right now because of
course as everybody knows Avengers 4 is
currently doing reshoots so a lot of
people are saying the only reason Tyga
is here is cuz he's doing reshoots for
Corrigan now of course this is just
speculation by fans yet script with 142
you know what you up for those as
Guardians man they are thought to perish
although the Russo brothers were pretty
vague when it came down to telling what
happened to Korg after the snap whether
he survived or didn't survive they never
really gave us an answer and it's been
widely speculated that Valkyrie and cord
will make an appearance in Avengers 4
but it is worth noting that this is the
opening night for a restaurant that Joe
Russo owns so he simply could have just
invited people and tyka is one of the
people that showed up however he is
shooting a movie of his own right now so
it's not very likely that he showed up
just to have a meal and doing reshoots
is the perfect opportunity to throw our
favorite character Corrigan there but
who knows he could just be there to
support a friend fans have been
petitioning for court to be an Avengers
4 and Avengers infinity war for that
matter for a very long time now so let's
hope that we get to see another
in Avengers 4 one day you ask if just
listen I was asking was it just you the
Lord of thunder sends his best
the revolution has begun let me know
what you all think this photo means and
if you think we'll see Korg and Avengers
4 and another reminder about the
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber like this video and
comment below with your thoughts and
your favorite superhero thank you so
much for watching
woof woof piss off ghost he's frickin
gone
[Music]